LeBron I know you said you're gonna lock
into things more on Thursday but what
are your early thoughts on the matchup
with Memphis and just oh I mean just a
really good team very well coached very
well balanced obviously the head of
snake is John Moran uh but another
All-Star Jaren Jackson who was up there
one of the defensive player of the year
there's a little block shots of the
offensively he's you know very dynamic
as well Ty's Jones uh the pointed off
the bench has led the league in the
assist turnover ratio like the last six
years so he compliments them very well
Desmond Bain I think in his third year
second or third year but he plays like a
like a veteran you know his ability to
shoot the ball from the three-point line
is also ability to you know attack an
early transition
um you know Dylan Brooks you know an
opportunity to go out there and and uh
you know you can't disrespect him
because he makes shots and
um you know and um you know Xavier
Tillman he's been playing good
basketball obviously Noel coach all the
way from college days you know with
Coach Izzo
um you know till now
um and so on and so on I mean you know
they got Lou canara Who broke my scoring
record in high school
passed me in high school and
the reason why because he has he's a
he's a laser from the three-point line
he's ability to shoot the ball
um you know it's uncanny and uh and they
got so many other guys also Off the
Bench that um you just you can't you
can't disrespect because they will it
will make you pay
um obviously I haven't thought about
Memphis in one minute
the last three will go Malika will go
Kurt and then we'll end with Tim Parker
LeBron you said that really you just
wanted a chance man